hey guys it is Friday which apart from
well and truly being the best day of the
working week also means I have this
week's top stories
all ready to go for you here's what
matters
this week there was some drama over
whether Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom
pains PvP mode would be locked behind a
paint wall or not our review of Peter
Brown found that the Forward Operating
Base PvP mode appeared to require real
world money to access the phantom pain
asks you to purchase in-game waters in
order to participate in PvP the page on
which you can do so states spend mb
coins paid service to purchase waters
Konami clarified by stating that once
service go live on September 1 and the
game is able to connect online more menu
options will become available on this
screen allowing you to choose to spend
in-game resources on MD cleanse
reviewers of the game were only allowed
to play the game offline Konami said
more information regarding the payment
models of forward operating base will be
provided closer to launch so we'll have
to wait and see how the game actually
incorporates the suspected
microtransactions
if you logged into Facebook on Monday
there is absolutely nothing special
about you as the social media giant has
announced that 1 billion people use the
service that day this is the first time
ever that so many people have logged in
on a single day
Facebook boss Mark Zuckerberg wrote on
his balls on Monday August 24 one in
seven people on earth used Facebook to
connect with their friends and family
adding he was proud of the global
Facebook community that impressive and
uncomfortably high statistic may say
something about where we're headed
although it might not be something we
should be proud of last year Facebook
bought oculus VR for two billion dollars
and reportedly over 200 million people
play games on Facebook every month so if
you're interested in what the future of
gaming holds you should definitely keep
an eye on what Facebook is doing and now
here are some games you can get for free
with your Xbox Live Gold subscription
all your PlayStation Plus subscription
next month's Playstations first vote to
play poll resulted in broke Ramon pious
ball being free for plus members in
September also free on here for our
super time force ultra Tesla grad and
xeodrifter here's three games you can
grab our Tesla grad and twisted metal
and the free Vita games are going to be
seared ripped up and la mulana ETS if
you're an Xbox person you can get the
dear God free all month for Xbox one and
Tomb Raider definitive edition from
September 16 to October 15 on Xbox 360
in the first half of the month you can
take up battle station Pacific and from
September 16 on wood you can grab a
crysis 3
if you played games in the 90s you may
remember truck the dinosaur hunting FPS
series this week we found out the games
are getting remastered Knight died
Studios who remastered System Shock 2
will be taking on the job of revamping
turrets
dinosaur hunter and struck two seeds of
evil the companies say they're committed
to restoring games so they can survive
through changing tech and updated
hardware the studio have said when Tarak
dinosaur hunter was first released it
was nothing short of revolutionary to
that point no game has ever offered the
combination of graphics and an
open-world environment that's rocks
featured and finally we like to
spotlight the most ridiculous things
happening around gaming and Just Cause 3
giving away an entire island is
definitely up there
in what has to be the most complicated
and ludicrous giveaway ever Square Enix
and developer Avalanche Studios
announced a Just Cause 3 promotion where
you can win an island an actual island
if you earn the most chaos points in
Just Cause 3 after the games have been
out for 90 days you have the chance to
win the island at valued at 50 grand if
that sounds too good to be true
don't worry this patch is coming in the
2,500 word terms and conditions square
writes all taxes and fees associated
with purchasing and obtaining of the
island including but not limited to
attorneys fees escrow and closing costs
are the responsibility of the winner
sponsor does not guarantee the island to
be inhabitable developed or reached by
any means other than a boat if you win
squirrel also letting you take the 50
grand in cash as opposed to the island
which might be a better idea if you're
interested you will need to have the day
one is
the game to participate let me know down
in that comment book that you'd rather
have the island all the money if you won
the Just Cause 3 competition and why
this week on site I tell you about the
very best b-movie games on the chest
Lucy discusses if video games make us
violent on reality check and Mary played
through until dawn that is everything I
wanted to tell you about this week let
me know what mattered to you as always
and we sort of have yourselves a lovely
weekend